en este vídeo vamos a practicar más cómo
se plantean los sistemas de ecuaciones
no resolverlos pero sí plantear los nos
dicen el perro de alva pesa 5 veces más
que su gato su perro también es 20
kilogramos más pesado que su gato seage
el peso del gato y pe el peso del perro
bien pausa el vídeo y ves puedes obtener
un sistema de ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas dos ecuaciones lineales con
dos incógnitas que podamos utilizar para
resolver g&p
muy bien hagámoslo juntos lo que me
gusta hacer usualmente hay una o dos
oraciones que describen cada una de las
ecuaciones que podemos proponer por
ejemplo aquí la primera oración dice el
perro de alba pesa cinco veces más que
su gato así que cuánto pesa su perro
bueno si su perro pesa pe entonces
sabemos que p
es igual a 15 veces más que su gato pero
su gato pesar g entonces es 5 veces el
peso del gato y esta es una ecuación
lineal usando ap viaje y cuál es la otra
bueno
después nos dicen su perro también es 20
kilogramos más pesado que su gato
entonces podemos decir que el peso del
perro
es igual al peso del gato más cuanto más
20 kilogramos suponiendo que todo está
en kilogramos entonces voy a poner más
20 aquí lo tienes acabo de plantear dos
ecuaciones lineales con dos incógnitas
dos ecuaciones lineales con base en la
información que nos da el problema
escrito y podemos después resolverlas es
más del cargo que lo hagas si eres
curioso pero algunas veces la parte
difícil es de expresar de una forma
matemática la información que te han
dado pero como verás a medida de que
practicas se vuelve algo intuitivo que
lo que vemos justo aquí de color azul es
otra forma de escribir lo que subrayamos
aquí en color azul y lo que vemos aquí
de color amarillo es otra forma de
escribir o de expresar lo que subrayamos
acá en color amarillo